hey it's alan today i'm going to be
trying three chinese dishes from three
different girls and then i'm going to
pick a date based on which dish i like
the most i have no idea what they look
like so this should be super fun i was
raised eating chinese food 24 7 at home
my parents came from fujo and i would
also go back and forth to china for my
production for my clothing brand so
being away from home now and like barely
seeing my parents i do miss chinese food
like good chinese food hi i'm claire hey
guys i'm becky hi i'm kuna who do you
think is going to win i think i'm going
to win i mean
sorry cut
do you have any clapbacks
i think it's gonna depend on what what
kind of man mr allen king is how
confident do you feel that you're gonna
win not really you know
but it's okay i tried my best which is
fine i would say even though i am in
fashion i haven't really i had like a
vegan salad phase for a little bit you
know but then i was like hey i really
miss korean barbecue people care a lot
about the plating and sometimes i do but
most of the time i'm just eating because
i'm hungry you know and i'm just like i
want it to taste good and i want to eat
it for the nutrients and like i have to
eat as a human i do like tomatoes and i
do like eggs so i hope there is a tomato
and egg dish or something
today i made fried rice originally i was
going to make it with chinese sausage
but unfortunately our man doesn't eat
pork i told the girls that you don't eat
pork
they were kind of frustrated so i
stuffed turkey bacon not the most
authentic thing we'll call it fusion add
an extra dollar sign on there yeah
normally i just don't have that much
time so it's kind of either i cook and i
make something really fast and easy or i
get takeout i make like a huge thing of
it in the beginning of the week and then
you can eat it every day i think it's
not it's fine
oh okay i do like fried rice man this
kind of looks like pork might be spam i
don't know what it's not pork oh mystery
meat i don't actually cook so this is a
very subjective
judgment i do know that fried rice is
really easy to make but i would say
maybe the girl is thinking about time
constraints
she's just like hey this is the most
efficient way to go about this that's
exactly what i was thinking we gotta go
we gotta go which i think is very
logical you know what honestly i would
probably have done the same or i would
have made dumplings that was my other
option but you don't eat pork it suits
your lifestyle yeah yeah you know what
it does it does she gets it she gets it
i get it a man's busy a woman's busy
this is kind of like the real chinese
version of it where you just don't
really fry it that much even though it's
called fried rice i don't really like
crispy fried rice so you just want
steamed rice with stuff folded into it a
little bit it's pretty straightforward i
mean it has like the basic ingredients
you know it has like peas corn mystery
meat it's turkey bacon
couldn't couldn't taste that
it's very tasty and delicious i can't
cook fried rice so you know well done
you were the one who said it was easy
you know what that's gonna be one of the
criteria now going forward we're gonna
start tearing this out
it's gonna be sauce plating
difficulty level different company
i almost feel like fried rice is
american chinese food when like chinese
fast food came around fried rice became
more integrated because before then it
was like white rice porridge i ate it
that's
every weekend sir but that's to my
understanding you know my parents used
to run a chinese restaurant i don't
really know the history of fried rice
deep in china enough but it is chinese
there's not that much to say about it
difficulty level i don't know i kind of
want to see the other dishes he wants to
see it not your auditions
[Music]
i made sweet and sour shrimp with rice
on the side i like to do like fresh
vegetables fresh meat fish everything
there's green peppers orange red peppers
and then there's cilantro here and then
this is shrimp with its shell oh you
didn't peel it for him though i'm gonna
have to take off ten points for that oh
my god we're giving him a homemade
assignment too
i think he'll be able to handle it do i
start reacting now yeah oh okay okay i
like that there is a side of rice very
crucial he's impressed
he's smiling he's happy this has the
skin on it yeah i was surprised she
didn't peel the shrimp for you
chris you are so mean i think i would
have thought like somebody would peel
the skin maybe it's because it's fried
together or prepared together in some
way because i do feel like the shrimp is
a little crunchy i mean without the
shell the shrimp shakes really small
it's a lot of pepper he doesn't like
spicy
i wonder why she put so many pepper
flakes in this actually he doesn't like
spicy yeah maybe not spicy it's kind of
spicy i told them you couldn't handle
spice i feel like the pepper overpowers
all the sauce you're doing okay
all i'm tasting is pepper because i'm
spicy like that so it's a little hard
for me to eat this dish if there was no
pepper in this this is a pretty solid
dish was this intentional
wait i had chopsticks yeah oh my bad was
supposed to be with chopsticks
you just threw it this makes more sense
actually all right don't hold that
against her that was my bag
there's a high potential here you know
pepper is something that can be taken
out let me test this this rice hold on
i think i think that's all he got
standing here
i mean what can i say
feeding him so he got scandal um
oh wow
all right kuna how are you feeling about
your dish today i don't know i really
don't know like i'm making a chinese
dessert it's like salted duck egg yolk
pastry and i made extra so you can try
it afterwards there's salted duck egg
yolk in there also red bean paste the
red bean will make it really sweet but
then the egg yolk is salty so it's like
savory i love making those these are so
tasty it smells good actually i can
smell this from pretty far away it was
like fresh out of the oven
this is good wow wow
oh he did this
this is really good
it's in the bag it's in the bag this is
like
taro paste and yolk
red bean juice cloth
caramel maybe i think it's brown sugar
i'm actually super impressed that she
can make this restaurant quality you
know like oh he kept doing this
i would say the yolk sometimes can be
like too dry but this one has a little
bit of the moisture in there the paste
that's around it is really good but it's
not super sweet it works really well
together with the yolk and the yolk is
not extremely salty it kind of is
balanced out by the sweetness of the
paste suddenly he's an expert i know
right i'm super impressed oh she chose
this plating this this plate yeah so i
gave her a white dish and she apparently
switched it i really like the color
contrast i think she also chose really
good complementing colors complementary
colors
plating well he's like a fashion
designer so like he like actually cares
about like that stuff this is really
good i don't think the test was really
main dishes so i feel like maybe she's
this is like the best dish like she's
super proud of i'm actually shocked she
can make this she says she makes that
all the time damn she must have a lot of
time on her hands too
hell no i was busy this must take a ton
of time to make too like if she makes
this all the time i was baking and
working this morning
it's actually very hard i feel like for
the fried rice over here i would
probably eat this on a daily basis this
girl kind of just gets me if she's just
like hey this is hella simple i'm just
gonna make this fried rice it'll be easy
now over here though we got the shrimp
and pepper plate i do like the plate it
was really awfully prepared with the
rice on the side i kind of wish it was
beef i don't know if there was a
shortcut to make shrimp i feel like it
was a little short cut it you know the
shrimp wasn't really peeled there was a
lot of peppers so maybe the sauce was a
little rushed maybe she just said it and
just
dumped a bunch of pepper in it but hey
like the rice was prepared on the side
it was a good dish you know it was a
good dish overall dish number three the
girl who prepared it she has so much
attention to detail and she really went
about this like i'm here to impress and
i don't think that anyone else on this
table really went about it as hard as
her i think this might be one of the
dishes that she's like not only do i
prepare this a lot but it's probably my
best dish i feel like that speaks
volumes for a person knowing hey like
this is my strength and i'm going to
present my strengths in whatever i do so
i really resonate with that it's a
little tricky it's a little tricky you
know i would love to see what the main
dishes look like for the girl who
prepared dish number three the only dish
i know this is hard this is hard i think
for sure number two is out you know
we're gonna put her over here oh my gosh
man
i think i would do this number three
because she just checked every single
box she possibly could have and i think
she really made it happen
let's do it let's meet them
how's it going oh my gosh
no i thought her dish was really cool i
was pretty surprised that you could make
that dish honestly well to be honest
that's the only dish i know how to make
so sorry well it's a great dish it's a
great dish to know how to make
it perfect okay so would you like to go
on a date
date is very time consuming i actually
spent a lot of time making the egg yolk
stuff so
if you had to pick a date spot kuna
where would you pick um this is a hard
question i'm probably very hard um we
could go watch a movie
you just you just went from time
consuming to watch a movie
that's like the most time consuming what
is the time we're gonna work together
and we work what is a time efficient
date though wait that's a good day you
guys just go to a co-working space and
work together that's cute oh oh that
would be great that would be ideal like
seriously it's a plan all right
cut
oh i can't i don't
[Music]
you